thiery verront à il est président de la
fédération des associations de
commerçants et artisans de paris thierry
berrod merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors vous faites partir
des signataires de cette tribune vous
demander au gouvernement à l'adoption
d'un moratoire sur les projets
d'entrepôts et méga centre du tri de du
e-commerce est ce que c'est la seule
façon de sauver les commerces de
proximité
alors il ya effectivement plusieurs
façons bonjour tout d'abord nous nous
avons co signé cette tribune parce qu'en
fait on se rend compte que le le
commerce de proximité est en train de de
s'effriter de plus en plus les les les
grandes chaînes comme amazon
alibaba qui va qui vont arriver un peu
plus tard aussi vont continuer de
supprimer les des commerces de proximité
alors effectivement il ya ce ce problème
là mais il ya plusieurs choses via
amazon
amazon qui peut ce clic et continue de
se développer mais ils vont se
développer aussi se développent de toute
façon au niveau de l'europe
moi je pense qu'en fait quelle action
qui peut être importante à faire c'est
de traiter au niveau de l'europe passe
question traite uniquement au niveau de
la france
amazon peut avoir des livraisons en
france depuis les pays limitrophes
ils seront peut-être pénalité pour les
gros paquets mais les petits paquets les
sous forme d'un blog ça peut partir des
pays limitrophes
donc en fait ce qu'il faut c'est que
l'on puisse arriver à trouver un juste
milieu parce qu'en fait il ya des
produits de qui sont vendus dans les
commerces de proximité et ses produits
de deux qualités qui sont vendus par les
petits commerces
on ne peut pas les trouver sur sûr
des sites comme amazon ou futurs ali
barra c'est comme des éléments très
importants
il faut tirer 8 à 11 projets amazon
alibaba vont ouvrir d'ici début 2011 21
on le disait et quatre ont déjà été
autorisées par l'état
est ce que vous estimez également payé
cutif doit faire marche arrière sur ces
dossiers alors il est clair qu'il faut
faire marche arrière il faut ralentir
considérablement ce développement parce
qu'en fait le petit commerce il va pas
se développer
de cette façon là puisque les toute
façon le petit commerce
il est de proximité et dans les centres
villes donc il faut vraiment revoir la
copie de ses différentes implantations
puisqu'en fait on a les le problème de
l'amazone futur alibaba ça c'est le
e-commerce gérer deux à grande échelle
parce qu'ensuite il ya le e-commerce qui
peut justement venir contrer les amazon
etc
et développer donc le e-commerce pour
les petits commerçants pour les le
commerce de proximité mais il ya aussi
un autre phénomène qui continue de se
développer aussi en france c'est les
centres commerciaux en périphérie des
villes
et ça c'est un point très important
qu'il faut évidemment contrôler de près
au même titre que amazon arrive bientôt
au terme de ce journal néanmoins cette
dernière question parle beaucoup
d'écologie ces derniers jours elle
suscite beaucoup de réflexion est-ce que
selon vous les commerces de proximité
là aussi peuvent être une solution pour
être moins nocif pour la planète
bien évidemment les le commerce de
proximité
la proximité on en est tous les ans on
essaie de de trouver les produits à côté
de chez soi
et puis un commerce qui est dans un
quartier qui va vendre ses produits aux
riverains
du quartier où des villes de la côte est
puisque en fait moi qui suis aussi au
président de l'association des
commerçants de l'avenue du général
leclerc à paris dans le 14e jeu on voit
très bien que de toute façon il n'ya pas
que les riverains de l'avenue goût du
quartier mais il ya aussi des villes
alentour donc en fait c'est tout un
tissu local qui ce secret qui se
développe et c'est ça qui est important
il faut il faut le maintenir et on ne
pourra pas faire un développement de 2,2
de ce commerce local de proximité par
rapport à amazon vraiment besoin de deux
commerces de proximité et il faut les
préserver
merci beaucoup tiré verront d'avoir
répondu à nos questions j'appelle que
vous êtes président de la fédération des
associations de commerçants et artisans
de paris